my name is paulina jaramillo I'm an
assistant research professor in the
Department of Engineering and public
policy and I have been working for the
last couple of years on issues related
to the integration of large scale wind
in the US I will talk today about
hurricane risks to offshore wind farms
in the US so the title of my
presentation is will hurricanes clobber
offshore wind the u.s. is a good
offshore wind resource and there are
plans to start developing these
resources if we want to get to high
penetration of wind resources the way
wind resource is located all over
throughout the United States although
the most accessible offshore wind
resources are in the Atlantic coast and
the Gulf of Mexico as you know we get
hurricanes in the Atlantic coast and the
Gulf of Mexico and wind turbines are
vulnerable to hurricanes the pictures
here show wind turbines in Japan that
were buckled for as a result of a
typhoon in 2003 you can see that the
damage was severe to disturbance and
they were offline until they were
replaced turbines are designed for
European conditions where there are no
hurricanes and they have their design
speeds are equivalent to a category 2
hurricane so what you can see in this
graph is a cumulative distribution
function of the number of turbulence in
a 50-win 450 turban wind farm being
destroyed at different wind speeds and
the numbers in the upper level the chart
show you the hurricane category so you
can see that after category 3 you can
expect the turbines to be damaged we
developed a model to estimate
destruction buckling of winter wind
turbine towers in several locations in
the United States but I'm going to
present specifically for the goal the
case of Galveston Texas
this is a 50 turban wind farm and what I
show here is the cumulative distribution
of the number of towers that buckle in
this wind farm in a 20-year period what
you see highlighted in the with the red
lines is it's an explanation of what the
graph is showing and I've pointed out to
a point where five turbines being buckle
the probability of five turbines be or
more being buckled during the 20 years
20 year period so as I said there
there's a four percent probability that
more than five turbines are destroyed
during this 20-year period so that also
means there's a ninety-six percent
probability that less than five turbines
buckle in this 20-year period the same
example but with a higher number you
have a probability of only one percent
of losing more than 25 or half of your
turbines in this 20-year period the
other case we looked at was looking at
regional development so we looked at a
case where we installed 86 gigawatts of
capacity on offshore Texas so what I'm
showing in this graph is the cumulative
distribution function of losing a
certain amount of capacity over a return
period over a period of 2 5 10 15 20 or
25 or 30 years so the point I
highlighted in the graph that's the
30-year curve so what we're showing
there is that in that specifically
specific point I highlighted is that
there is a sixty-four percent
probability of losing at at least 7.5
gigawatts of your 86 gigawatts of
installed capacity that also means that
you have a forty percent probability of
losing more than 7.5 ego once this is
doing a 30-year period as the number of
years in your period decreases there's
there's a lower probability of Lou
into too much capacity because this is
dependent on Herc and intensely in
hurricane occurrence rates so you can
see that in two years there's a 90
there's only one percent probability of
losing maybe more than 2 gigawatts of
these 86 gigawatts so it depends your
return periods are really what dependent
your risk in the return period of
interest vary depending on what what
perspective you're taking if you're an
insurance company or if you're the power
grid or the investor the conclusions of
this project very generally speaking is
that we don't find that great
reliability is is a significant concern
related to installing high capacity of
wind offshore the wind the grid has the
abilities to plan for these losses
especially since hurricanes can be
predicted now the economic damages could
be severe if you're if you're losing if
you have 86 gigawatts of winning you're
losing a percentage of that that's
equivalent to millions of dollars of
losses so this might be a concern for
investors and insurance companies now
there are mechanisms that can be used to
reduce the risk to offshore wind
turbines I can mention before the
turbines that we currently have where
designed for European conditions so we
could design them for Atlantic or
hurricane prone regions we could for
example Purdue have backup power in the
in the wind farm so that when the wind
is not producing power you still have
access to power so the turbines can gnaw
and follow the wind and I have a graph
here that shows you how the probability
for the wind farm in Galveston that we
explore before decreases significantly
when the turbines can draw so the blue
line is the graph that I had see we had
shown previously where
this is the risk of losing a certain
number of turbines in a 20-year period
and the red dotted line is what happens
to a risk one the turbine can yo and you
can see that it's much higher which
means the probability was it slower of
damage of losing too many turbines is
lower you can also design stronger
blades and stronger towels then it will
require more material in the wind
turbines themselves or more steel and
carbon fiber which will likely increase
the price of the or the cost of the wind
turbine so there's a trade-off between
designing stronger wind turbines for
offshore and the cost finally we can
choose side there are less prone to
hurricanes and this figure here shows
you the wind resource the most
accessible wind resource in the
different states in the Eastern in the
eastern coast and the rate of hurricane
occurrence that has occurred since
records have begun so in the upper upper
corner Worth Texas in Louisiana and
North Carolina are those are states that
have significant wind resources but also
have the highest risk of having
hurricanes heat the turbines the other
states have a more more moderate wind
resource but they have lower probability
of having a hurricane hit the state so
what we suggested that if we want to
develop offshore wind wind we can start
developing inside where the risk of
hurricanes is lower and that's the end
of my my presentation if you have
any questions about this research you
can email me at paulina at CMU edu